we're delighted to have a melt in see
from master cell presenting for us today
after receiving a master's degree at the
University Louis Pasteur in France Amell
obtained her PhD in immunology and
cellular biology at the University
catholique de louvre are in Brussels she
then followed a post doctoral fellowship
at a German Cancer Research Center where
she worked in the establishment of in
vivo models in mice to study the immune
regulatory activity the bone marrow
derived mesenchymal stem cells after her
academic experience she joined the
research and development department of
cardio three by sciences now called
Sully add a Belgian biotech company
developing a stem cell therapy for the
treatment of chronic heart failure I'm
always involved in process improvement
and developed release and potency assays
expertise and academia are Indiana
biotech industry with an asset for
master cell where she has worked as
development and project manager since
August 2014
Thank You Freya for this very nice
introduction and thank you all for
joining us at this webinar well during
this presentation as you can see here on
the on the slide I will be discussing
about a project that was held at master
cell with two other collaborators at
Isis and tirumal and I will talk about
the project where we had to internalize
and upscale manufacturing of stem cell
therapies using the quantum expansion
system this slide here is to remind you
that master cell is a public company and
in order to be compliant with some legal
aspects I had to show this message
before moving through the description of
the case study itself let me just give
you a short introduction on massive fan
Masterson is a European contract
development and manufacturing
organization we are based in Belgium and
our
mission is to help our clients mainly
cell therapy companies move their
product faster to the markets and we do
so by proposing a one-stop shop company
where we can help our clients from the
tech transfer service to any development
manufacturing quality or logistic
aspects of their drug development in
order to keep up with our mission and
help our clients who make sure to
monitor and adapt to the market
challenges of course this is only
possible by collaborating with
scientific experts that can understand
and help the cell therapy biotech
companies in the drug development and
last but not least masterful experts in
operational know-how also here to advise
our clients on how to optimize their
production mainly according to the GMP
requirements another clear set of master
cell it's the 600 square metre eme a
compliant GMP facilities you can see
here a plan of the facilities and on the
bottom right you can see the tech
Watford lab where the work of this case
study was performed you see also that
metal cell has five clean rooms one
Treacy lab and a storage room dedicated
through our clients I was happy to
participate in this project as project
manager you can see in this slide that
this role is very central as it is
actually an interface between the
customers needs and master cell internal
team we make sure that we actually
answer our clients need by gathering the
best team internal as mentioned earlier
in this presentation this work was
performed with two other partners at
Asus and even room actually this was an
ideal car library
especially especially for a project
where bioreactor was tested and upscaled
the client wishing to test and optimize
the bio actor were part of the project
the bioreactor manufacturer thermo and
ourselves at the cinema city MO with the
GMP know-how and the JMP physiology as
oxygen analysis had a well-characterized
cell therapy product that needed to be
amplified to remember was offering a
bioreactor the quantum cell expansion
system by reactor based on the hollow
fiber technology master cell offered the
expertise on jam-filled cell therapy
manufacturing the purpose of the project
was to multiply by 10 the production of
Edessa cells preliminary work was
performed on one consume and the
strategy was to scale out the production
to running 10 Quantum's in parallel the
harvest production of one quantum
expansion system was of 1 billion cells
logically the run of 10 quantum parallel
would need to generate 10 billion cells
the challenge of this ten-time run was
the space and footprint of such
equipment the time challenge of
harvesting 10 Quantum's and respecting
the sales shelf life and training the
team to this larger scale and ensure of
course that all cells generated in the
10 Quantum's were homogeneous and
comparable to the one single quantum run
concerning the space as you consider the
work was performed in our tech transfer
lab this is a 32 square meter rule there
is non-classified but this is another
problem as the quantum system is a
closed system as you can see here in
this picture the tankinson were disposed
on tables that were 3 meter x 1.5 meters
large they were indisposed as five
Quantum's back to the other five
Quantum's and the both you see on the
front are gas bottles and connected to
the quantum in terms of space
organization it's of course important to
keep some space around the quantum so
that the operators can sample and
manipulate the quantum to laminar air
flow were placed facing each group of
five quantum expensive expensive system
from the way the operator is dressed you
can see that this is this lab is an
unclassified lab but as a quadrants
expansion system in a closed system the
back connection and sampling can be
performed even on an unclassified room
the sterility of the products was not
affected as this was confirmed by the
the testings performed at the end of the
other one I wanted to give you as many
practical details from this study and I
think that the insight on the on the
timelines is an important one the
expansion process for each one was of
the six days and it is represented in
this slide by a blue line the QC testing
were performed after the realms and
represented two weeks but if you don't
see them represented here on the scheme
for all the products we had three phases
the first one can concerned the training
and Technology Transfer that lasted for
only four weeks and this is was mainly
due to the by rector manufacturer
support general in the training and also
to the initial work performed at
resonances and addresses that actually
made a pre-optimized ation of the
protocol of amplification of the of
those cells in the quantum expansion
system once the first three training
rods were performed on single quantum
systems
the GC testing confirmed that the
self-generated were equivalent to the
client cells and then we decided to move
to the next step which was the process
optimization at Madison the run in this
phase were also performed on single
Quantum's
and actually aimed at improving the
process optimization was mainly
performed on culture media flow
optimization culture media consumption
and self feeding timing once the process
was optimized the decision was taken to
move to the ten quantum scale utterance
two of them were performed as you can
see here in the last phase of the of the
project you notice that the timing
between the small scale the single
quantum runs and the ten quantum
extension runs in parallel was only done
after a week and I think that's another
advantage of choosing scaling out versus
Caleb you don't change
actually your bioreactor system so that
makes life easier and moving from one
step to the other faster another
important topic in the production of
self products is the workload associated
in this slide we made the comparison
between a single quantum run in the
bottom of the scheme and a scaled out
times 10 quantum run in the upper vital
part of the scheme the process as
mentioned previously is a six-day
process with a day of preparation in
order to recruit the other fibers of the
bio actor the time required by each
operator was represented by orange lines
and you can see here that in conclusion
the the workload associated with a scale
out so if we are at multiplying by 10
our production we're only increasing by
3.5 times to work the workload well you
mainly need more time for the quoting
the daily monitoring
other other than that the harvest had
timing had to be kept the same between
the singular and Anderton quantum runs
as you know this is requested by the
manufacturer and made a company that the
freezing solution and the harvested
cells stay at the same time out of the
Quantum's so therefore another an
additional operator was required to to
keep those tight timing I also wanted to
speak briefly about the harvest day and
the dumpster and pulling steps of the
ten quantum runs
actually no specific or additional
equipment other than the centrifuge were
needed to wash and concentrate the cells
and as the cells one harvested needed to
be frozen under the same timing as for a
single quantum run which was Arvest the
first for then the second floor and then
the last to Quantum's together once all
tears will were washed and concentrated
they were pooled and conditioned for
freezing in this slide you can see that
in both fronts using the ten Quantum's
in parallel we managed to generate
around a billion cells per quantum just
as for the single quantum runs
proliferation efficiency was not lost
moreover the viability of the cell was
above the 95 percent and the viability
in cell yield was of 12% as mentioned
previously even though the work was done
in an unclassified room we had to prove
that the cells were safe and therefore
conducted the usual safety tests at
master cell the sturly test using the
bacterial art methods the mycoplasma
test using a validated qPCR method here
at master cell and the on the toxin
detection using the lyle cryogenic test
all three tests were done according to
the european pharmacopoeia and show to
be negative for all samples
run seven was a single quantum run while
run nine and ten where ten quantum runs
would prove that the handling of the
back culture and sampling did not affect
the closed system and generated self
cells even in a non classified area in
order to prove to our clients that the
scaling out did not affect the sales
characteristic the usual negative
markers were tested for for their selves
and they showed to be negative in both
single and ten quantum runs while
they're positive markers have the same
level of expression expression on both
single and ten quantum runs again
validating here the comparability
between both frauds another important
parameter to show the comparability of
the cell generated from a single and a
ten quantum runs was the potency of the
cells antis is considered their self as
potent if they secreted a certain number
of proteins and virginity's performed
those testings and confirmed that the
potency of the cells was equivalent in
both single and thank want quantum run
equivalent in this slide I wanted to
summarize the conclusion made during
this project first of all we were very
surprised by the ease of manipulation of
such a bioreactor the operators involved
in the project have never worked with a
quantum before and could easily learn
and operate independently the bio actor
that by the end of the training by the
end of the training period which was
already after month this of course led
to a significant decrease in the project
time timelines and therefore we could
run all development tech transfer and 10
quantum runs in just 16 weeks on the
other hand we also fulfilled our
challenge to increase the cell expansion
capacity of our client by about 900
percent
in reference to a single quantum run the
comparability studies showed that the
cells generated after scale-out were
equivalent in terms of safety yield and
potency to the single quantum runs
another important element concerns the
workload it is interesting to note that
by increasing the labor by only 3.5
times we could multiply by 10 the cell
production and I also would like to
remind you that all the work was done in
a 32 square meter non-classified tech
transfer lab it's an important
information for a manufacturing
organization as cleanroom footprint is
essential in the central parameter in
the cost of cell therapy production the
other advantage we also seen in this
project that this scale out of the
process did not modify the process
length and maintained it at 6 days and
the training of a team actually to move
from a small single quantum production
scale to a 10 quantum scale out
manufacturing scale actually was not
required as they were actually ready to
do to go from one one system to the
other I wanted to close this
presentation by thanking all the people
that were involved in this project I
remind her that we worked with several
collaborators at Asus and their company
here in Belgium the genesis as well as
during obesity and I really would like
to thank all of them for their help and
support throughout the project I hope
that you all enjoyed this presentation
[Music]
I wanted to give you some practical
insight you know on the on the scale out
of manufacturing cell therapy and moving
from one by reactor to running ten in
parallel with the challenges that it
takes of course I am now ready to answer
all your questions and if you need any
further information on myself silicon
also contact us
Thank You dr. Kunze for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the green two minute
button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button will answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for your questions will be answered
today by dr. wingman Liang cell
processing specialist Asia Pacific at to
remote VCT wenyan liang ph.d is the
regional specialist for the quantum cell
expansion system responsible for
managing knowledge transfer and
implementation of efficient and safe
manufacturing solutions in the
biotechnology cell therapy field dr.
Liang works very closely with various
industry representatives researchers and
regulatory agencies in Asia Pacific she
is passionate about the advancements in
cell based therapy and seeks active
dialogue with stakeholders in the field
on how to bring research ideas into the
industry prior to joining the cell
processing team of teramo BCG she spent
four productive years in academic
research on cell based regenerative
medicine platforms working on a variety
of biological cells and biomaterials her
contribution of ten research articles
and three patents to this specialty
resulted in a PhD bioengineering confirm
it from Nanyang Technological University
Singapore now let's get to our questions
our first question is
are you able to provide an estimate of
cost of goods for producing 1 billion
cells did this scale out linearly for
the 10 times manufacturing scale thank
you for your question
we have various customer excites we'll
analyze the cost of goods for quantum
raises their manual processes we are
unable to provide a universal estimate
because of the variability in process
and protocol across different sites and
countries when manufacturing is scaled
up to several quantum systems the cost
of goods is expected not to scale out
linearly this is a nonlinear increase in
infrastructure space and labor in the
effortless Regenesis and max virtual
study where they scaled out from one
quantum to 10 quantum systems there was
no need to increase space when team of
two operators labor-hours wide there was
a 3.5 times increase operating sent ones
and systems compared to a single quantum
the study also reverses a 40% reduction
in cost of goods relatives to manual
manufacturing methods this cost of goods
observation is quite consistent with
those mentioned in other sites for
example Mayo Clinic and Kuiper's all
thank you next question is what protein
do you use for coating and at what
concentration we use five milligrams of
fiber next chain to coax the bioreactor
thank you have any studies been
performed in the quantum to induce
differentiation in the bioreactor in
situ for example hepatic there has been
some work into differentiation in the
quantum cell expansion system however
there are these are customers sites and
we are not able to disclose any
specifics
thank you what
so this association reagent is used for
harvest in most of our work with
customers we use whatever reagent the
customer has been using most will use
3.25% trypsin with EDTA thank you I
noticed that you hang five liter bags on
the bioreactor how many days does a five
liter bag go through do you keep the
bags at room temperature with no
protection from light thank you for
question so the media that are for
research and capacities the quantum cell
expansion system is the perfusion based
system which means there is a continuous
feed rate and waste removal how long a
bet can last therefore depends on the
feed rate which is adjusted through the
culture to prevent the cells of
sufficient nutrients typically for a
seven-day culture of adult mesenchymal
stem cell of passage one and a book we
use six to eight liters of media to
obtain 250 to 750 million cells the
backlog kept at room temperature with no
protection from life however
if there are sensitive media components
we do protect these backs from life by
wrapping them in tinfoil thank you is
the harvest time exactly six days from
plating the cells into the reactor the
duration of culture depends on the cell
type and server are the factors
including passage number doubling time
and media components ultimately it
depends on the cell growth curve the end
goal is to achieve maximum number of
cells in a healthy State
therefore we aim to harvest before the
cell growth curve which is the
stationary phase the next question is I
know the quantum gives you the option to
use protein free media in the extra
capillary loop and complete media in the
interim capillary loop in order to save
on media did you try this capability yes
in some of our customers sites we have
performed a dual media feed strategy
thank you the next question is did you
load the cells using Rock inhibitor no
that has not been a request to when we
work with customers on transferring the
process from manual to the quantum Excel
expansion system we try our best to
follow the manual protocol in terms of
the reagents use thank you we have time
for one last question and that question
is did you find it necessary to change
the composition of the cell culture
media from a normal culture to the
hollow fiber system thank you for your
question no we have not found a need to
change the composition of the cell
culture media customers have been using
I would like to once again thank dr.
tunze for her presentation and dr. Liang
for answering questions I would also
like to thank lab roots interim o BCT
for making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through March 12th 2018 you will receive
an email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues you may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon goodbye